we've had the guys open we just missed
them
and uh there are times when coverage
dictates you go to that guy
so um i think we can do a better job
of utilizing the deep ball in our game
plan
uh more up or less of so each each and
every week so different
but uh when they're there we need to hit
them we can't have them going off our
fingertips and we can't overthrow them
we have tom calling a lot of his own
we're picking his own on the sidelines
you know from the game plan so
i don't think it's a confidence problem
whatsoever it's just still
some it's not lack of trust it's just
lack of continuity within the offense
all right christopher is suffering from
a condition that my wife would very much
like to acquire the inability to hear me
we will get that fixed and chris will be
rejoining us very soon it's kind of hard
to have a conversation
when one of the parties involved can't
actually hear what the other person is
saying
we've heard plenty of what bruce arians
has had to say this year about tom brady
and it times its passive aggressive at
times it's aggressive aggressive
lately it's been more subtle but when
you string together the various words
and when you add to what he said
yesterday
things that were uttered during his
weekly radio show
on tuesday night there really is a sense
that
the blame is being placed on brady not
the coaching staff
not the playbook not the game plan not
the play calling
not the blocking not the receivers
receivers are open
bruce aryan says the pass blocking
against the rams was very good
aryan says aryan said last night
on his radio show that on offense it
comes down to whether or not
the quarterback plays well period and he
also
reiterated that the second interception
thrown by brady the one that clinched
the game with
fewer than two minutes to go when the
buccaneers were trying to drive
for a potential game-tying field goal or
game-winning touchdown
that was a poor throw poor decision poor
read now at times
aryans will say well he needs continuity
he needs more
reps well he needs to say that more
often because
all too often it's a slap at tom brady
a poor throw a poor decision a guy's
open blocking's there
and chris is back chris hi we've been
talking
about the i hear you i'm serious
comments it's great to have you back
oh my god messing with your courts i
don't know whatever it was
it's just like covet whatever it is it's
your fault that it happened i'll take it
it's your fault that you couldn't
take the responsibility i'm back out
here i'm ready to go i mean
yeah i've i've heard a little bit about
what you were saying there i missed the
the start of the segment
of course saw the bruce aryan's uh
comments and everything like that
you know mike i i don't know exactly
where you left off
but here's what jumps out to me all
right with the brady it
is very weird what's going on right now
it just seems like there's a clash of
cultures
that's really all there is to it you
know it to me
seems like hey brady wants to run
shotgun
spread it out i'll pick you apart five
and six yards at a time
be surgical that's how smart he is right
that's the biggest strength in his game
his brain his experience
all the defenses he's seen all of that
that's great
but tampa's not like that they don't
have
bruce arians and byron leftwich don't
have the extensive spread offense and
all the rules and
creative ways that we saw brady exposed
teams with for so long in new england
they're not
bruce arians his whole life has played a
different style of football
so he's not going to have 150 plays
for tom brady to pick apart people you
know five and eight and ten yards at a
time
and that's where it's a clash of
cultures that way and
they can't offer that part of their
offense for brady to
you know take it over that that
that style of football play and then
what they want him to do is of course
hold the ball make plays in the pocket
do things like that
throw the ball down the field he doesn't
want to do that
you can see that he doesn't want to pull
the trigger into tight windows down the
field
and he doesn't want to stand in the
pocket you know again we could talk
about
sunday night or monday night football
again they tried to make a deal like he
was getting
pressured on tv and it was just the
opposite of that
the numbers bear that he got pressured
what
the eighth least in football last week
so the protection was phenomenal
you know no everybody makes excuses for
tom brady that's where i came to my
wit's end you know hey he's 43.
he's allowed everybody else is expected
to move in the pocket
make a play do something but for brady
it's like hey he didn't have seven
seconds to throw
that's messed up let's do a pack on
brady being pressured he's only getting
seven seconds every time he drops back
to pass that's just bs i'm sorry i'm
gonna call like it is
people are scared to say it because it's
tom brady and all those things
but nobody he gets he gets a different
standard and maybe he's earned that to a
degree but you know i'm from the uh what
have you done right now this is football
right now
you know we'll talk about 20 2004 you
know after when we have a beer or
whatever but right now we're talking
about football now and this is the issue
with the bucks and and where they're at
with their offense
well i think one of the reasons you and
i get along so well is that we both
agree with this concept that if everyone
else out there is going to blindly heap
praise on someone
we're going to fill in the gaps to be
filled in
right point out point out that that
piece of spinach
that is uh clinging to tom brady's teeth
when everyone else is afraid to do so
because it's only fair and it's only
proper we criticize those who deserve to
be criticized
we praise those who deserve to be
praised and i think when we see someone
being praised
over the top who doesn't deserve to be
praised over the top
we have to call it out right and you
know aryans talked about this
potential tension between
what plays their calling and throwing
the ball down the field and he said we
have tom calling a lot of his own plays
or picking his own plays on the sideline
yeah
from the game plan so that's the thing
that i can't figure out
is this tom brady wanting to show off
his arm
or is this bruce aryan's no risk it no
biscuit
and one of the flaws in no risk at no
biscuit is the quarterback's got to have
enough time to biscuit
that's right and he did and he did and
he did
and he's yeah but he's 43 and he's just
not gonna take over
games that way anymore he wants to take
them over mentally
don't make me have to do too much
physically let my mind
and my arm and accuracy just do it and
go from there
but he's with a team that like we talked
about just doesn't have the
you know extensive offense and plays in
all that way
to really utilize brady's greatest
strength at this point of his career
and we're seeing yeah there's a
reluctance in brady
to like we saw in the deep ball last you
know we saw one that went off antonio
brown's fingertips hey sure
we saw other ones that weren't even
catchable i mean come on this is
arguably the greatest quarterback of all
time
he's not even giving them a chance so
he's got to be a little bit more
aggressive and
fearless that way to two to just go all
right it's a 50 50 ball but it's not
really a 50 50 ball with mike evans it's
more like a 70 30 ball when you have a
guy like him
but he's making it a zero zero ball and
not even giving him a chance or anything
like that
you know so i think there is that aspect
and i think bruce arians is frustrated
probably with
the yeah having to do both offenses
and he's used to guys being aggressive
he comes from
big ben and peyton manning and you know
even carson palmer and of course jameis
winston who was like
aggressive aggressive aggressive so what
i threw 45 interceptions not gonna
he that's what he wants and that's just
not the way tom brady is at this point
of his career
if he got tom brady 8 10 12
years ago hey they did probably work and
it'd be unbelievable i don't doubt that
but right now for where brady is
he's not going to want to stand in there
and do some of those things that we saw
big ben and payton do under bruce arians
back in their primes
and here's where some of the subtlety
creeps in because we're used to bruce
aryan's
clobbering you over the head with his
words and not
mincing in any way the words he uses to
explain a situation he was asked
yesterday about the criticism
that the offense isn't fitting what tom
brady
does well to your point not being spread
out
forcing him to throw the deep ball aryan
said
of brady he can do anything so it's not
like he can't do it
i see him do it all the time right
that to me yes is
yeah and it's and it's it's in practice
it's fine that's about the deep ball in
practice
we connect on those all the time in
practice he said
aryan said so yes something's going
wrong in the games but chris
where does the responsibility of the
coach
to understand that there is a disconnect
and to adjust accordingly and i just
wonder where brady is in all this
why isn't he taking over like peyton
manning did in denver
and saying this is what i want to do
this is what i'm going to do hey byron
leftwich
put this in the playbook this is what
i'm going to call this is the play i
want
they're creating the impression he's
doing that and it's still not working
that's what makes this all so damn
awkward yeah no you're right
you know first off with the deep balls
and practice and all those things that's
where i'll go back he can't be hit in
practice there's no pressure there
there's no pressure mentally or
physically
so obviously there's something that goes
on with the game there
uh that that changes the way he throws
it or his approach to it or whatever
you know you bring up the peyton manning
thing certainly it's a little different
situation
because he took over at a place that
you know was a defensive head coach adam
gase was a young offensive play caller
right and they they kind of did it a
collaborative
you know effort oh and wanted to go to
that style of football play they started
they get wes welker right they got those
guys you know some of these receivers
and this maybe this is why they got
antonio brown mike evans isn't
made to play the julian edelman new
england offense he's not built for that
so he doesn't really fit it
chris godwin to a degree but he's still
not a julian edelman wes welker type
he's not that kind of guy he could do
some of that stuff
you know antonio brown can fit into that
role a little bit maybe that's why they
went that way
but i think that's where it's different
than denver and hey let's not forget in
denver mike too
you know in denver ultimately they lose
the super bowl and do that thing lose
the next year right in the divisional
round to
uh that was the colts in 2014 right
but john elway made a decision said hey
look
it's cool we look cool we're throwing 50
touchdown passes and do all that crap
but we're not going to beat the good
teams in the afc playoffs or win a super
bowl
if we continue to worry about our
passing stats and numbers and things
like that so he calls gary kubiak and
things change that way right
and they played a different style
football to win the super bowl and i
think bruce arians and brian leftwich
thought that maybe
they could slowly mold a brady into what
they wanted
just through pushing him and success and
all that i think it's taken a little
longer than we all thought it would
the entire situation reminds me of one
of my favorite all-time lines from the
office which will be streaming
exclusively on peacock coming up in
january
michael and jan seem to be playing their
own separate game and it's called let's
see how uncomfortable we can make our
guests
and they're both winning that's the
situation in tampa as of right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports